a esta hora de la noche se sienten aún
los coletazos del día más caliente en la
historia del reino unido- con una
temperatura récord de 40.3 grados de
temperatura han sido tan altas las
temperaturas aquí en londres que los
bomberos de la ciudad decretaron el
estado de emergencia para atender al
menos 10 incendios varios de ellas de
gravedad pero también se reportaron
otros incidentes en todo el país esta
ola de calor que no sólo afecta
fuertemente al reino unido- sino a otros
países de europa en este país por
ejemplo ha generado disturbios
problemas con el sistema de transporte
terrestre porque por ejemplo las vías de
los trenes se han ensanchado por el
calor así que los operadores han
advertido que este miércoles puede haber
grandes demoras mientras se restauran
pero también en el transporte aéreo y
millones de jóvenes y de niños no
pudieron asistir a clases físicamente
por esta ola de calor en este momento ha
empezado a llover en algunas zonas del
país
la agencia meteorológica británica ha
emitido una alerta amarilla por posibles
tormentas eléctricas en el norte de
inglaterra y algunas regiones de escocia
por el cambio tan abrupto tan drástico
de las temperaturas a quienes el reino
unido- los expertos han llamado
nuevamente la atención de los gobiernos
del gobierno de la población para que se
adopten rápidamente medidas que ayuden a
combatir los efectos del cambio
climático que son cada vez más una
realidad y se advierte que las olas de
calor serán mucho más fuertes y más
frecuentes en el futuro